at il fait beau je me sens très bien
rien de tel qu'une petite promenade dans
les bois pour vous mettre en forme j'ai
une faim je lis je lis j'ai très faim
ouvre-moi julie ouvrant c'est moi je gfa
julie je suis là mais comment as tu fait
pour sortir de près par le tue comment
as tu fait pour sortir sans que je te
vois je tu peux sortir ce n'était pas
dans mon kiosque au mais je comprends
pas
normalement tu es tous les jours quand
on cause qu'à cette heure-là mais
aujourd'hui des pages jour comme les
autres
tu n'as rien remarqué remarquez qu
est-ce qu il y a qu est ce qui se passe
arrête de tourner comme ça regarde sous
son nez je n'ai pas donné
excuse moi sur le kiosque alors sur le
kiosque
ah oui je n'ai pas vu c'est joli comment
est-ce que tu as accroché maya nouveau
qu'elle est accrochée là je ne comprends
pas j'ai fait le tour du kiosque elle
n'avait rien remarqué
c'est normal tu l'avais sous le nez je
n'ai pas donné d'accord
disons que tu étais trop près pour la
voir pourquoi trop près parce que tu ne
pouvais saisir que des détails
insignifiants pour voir l'ensemble de la
fiche il faut se reculer ah oui c'est
vrai oui je vends beaucoup mieux la
fiche parce que je suis un peu loin
et qu'est ce que tu vois je crois que
j'avais oublié de la lire oui attend
aujourd'hui leçons de cuisine par julie
voix formidable j'ai justement une de
ses fins alors
ce que tu va cuisiner gâteau un gâteau
aux poires formidable
laisse moi deviner c'est une tarte aux
cerises avec des oignons
certainement pas alors un gâteau au
chocolat avec des anchois encore moins
alors je donne ma langue au chat
ben tu vas voir les enfants venez allégé
carole j'ai apporté pour faire un gâteau
du sucre du beurre des oeufs et de la
farine et il n'y a pas de mayonnaise ni
d'escargots ça ne fait pas partie de ma
recette alors ton gâteau va être très
mauvais attends moi je vais te montrer
comment on prépare un excellent gâteau
voilà je vais vous préparer un gâteau
formidable gélas du sucre de la farine
de la confiture et the du fromage des
six morts du saucisson
et de lag on va écouter casimir arrête
parce que moi j'ai la tête qui tourne je
vais donner ma leçon de cuisine pendant
ce temps tu vas faire ton gâteau et on
verra quel est le meilleur comparé un
gâteau formidable alors voilà les
enfants ont mais en quantités égales le
sucre le beurre les oeufs et la farine
on commence par les eaux on met le jaune
vous me regardez bien pour pouvoir le
faire chez vous voilà on met 4e parce
que chaque oeuf pèse environ 60 grammes
alors ça fait environ 250 grammes 4g 250
g de sucre de beurre et de farine
après on met le sucre à vous retenez
bien et vous chez vous aussi le sucre et
les jaunes on les mélange bien quand ils
sont bien mélanger on ajoute la farine
c'est le gâteau le plus simple ça
s'appelle un 4/4 parce qu'il ya une
quantité égale de chaque ingrédient la
farine et le beurre
on mélange un peu encore la farine et le
beurre on le met petit à petit en elle
là je vais le mettre bien mou ou qui se
mélangent plus facilement
voilà et on mélange tout ça jusqu'à
obtenir une pâte bien homogène
après avoir mélangé d'ailleurs avec la
cuillère c'est plus facile une fois
qu'on obtient une patate plus mélangé de
prendre les mains voila quand les jaunes
le sucre et la farine sont bien
amalgamer on bat les blancs en neige
on met un petit peu de salles pour
qu'ils montrent mieux
voilà alors quand les blancs sont battus
en neige
on les ajoute à la pâte on re mélange
tout ça soit à nouveau bien homogène et
voilà ça va être prêt à cuire
qu'est ce que c'est 1 4 k il ne reste
plus qu'à le faire cuire et le cas ça va
encore 2 2 voilà bien alors il ne reste
plus qu'à rappellent ceux ci sont
maintenant bon bain tout à l'heure à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
oh
les enfants venaient le gâteau est cuit
vous venez le goûter les enfants venez
goûter le meilleur des gâteaux c'est
avec ton mélange de tout alors que tu
fais ça ouais et alors c'est incroyable
alors mais non c'est normal puisque je
suis le meilleur des pâtissiers salut
tiens mais qu'est ce qui se passe mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça casimir et
m'en viens de faire un concours de
pâtisserie et regarde ce qu'il est
arrivé à faire avec de la farine du
beurre de l'aïe
oui un du gruyère de la confiture de
framboises et du saucisson mais ça doit
être est mangeable
bon moi je ne trouve pas promis d'armes
et toi je suis sûr que tu vas adorer
non mais tu vois casimir je préfère
goûter le gâteau de julie une bonne part
prendre et il est très facile à faire
j'espère que vous avez retenu la recette
et bien maintenant tout le moins bien
mais juste un petit morceau vol par
curiosité
attention il ya aussi du piment de
survie mot est bien allons-y
alors il est très beau
les meilleurs des deux ayoubi j'ai gagné
je finis meyer quasi vertu valeurs bien
des paroles je viens de gagner le
concours de gâteaux le concours des
gâteaux maintenant moi je rencontrais le
pâtissier et il m'a demandé de temps m
la facture du gâteau à la crème que tu
te fais livrer tout à l'heure tient pas
par exemple mais alors tu as triché
casimir
15 me
[Musique]